I chose to break this problem down into three parts.
In the first part, the block is moving from exactly the center
where it just hit the timer over to the spring.
In the second part it's in contact with the spring compressing it and then finally extending again,
and in the third part, the block is moving to the right back towards the timer.
Note that this problem is completely symmetrical, so it's sufficient for me to solve
the problem on one side, and I now the same thing is going to happen for me on the other side.
I only need to solve for one period of the block moving over here and bouncing back to the timer.
I know the same thing is going to happen on the right side.
In the first part, the block needs to travel a distance of 1.5 m and it's going in a velocity of V₀.
I'm going to use this kinematics equation here
and I know that the acceleration is going to be zero during this part
so I can cross out this term, and doing a little algebra and plugging in my values here,
I find that the time it takes for the block to move this distance of 1.5 m is equal to 1.5/V₀.
I'm actually going to skip part two for a second and move on to part three.
And in part three we said that the block is moving to the right
and needs to cover the same distance of 1.5 m again, and we know from conservation energy
that the kinetic energy of the block has to be the same both before and after
it makes contact with the spring, which means that its speed will actually remain the same
both before and after since the mass is remaining the same.
This means that part three is actually an exact mirror image of part one.
The block is just moving to the right this time over a distance of 1.5 m
at the same speed V₀, except this time it's to the right.
We could actually conclude right away that the time for part three
is just equal to 1.5/V₀ just like part one.
Now what about part two, well I made the argument in the question
that the time that the block stays in contact with the spring is actually equal to 1/2 of the period.
Not the full period of the oscillation of the spring, and this is because at this point
the spring is just about to pull back on the block, but because the block isn't attached
the spring can't actually pull back on the block.
The block is free to move with the same velocity it has at this point,
which happens to be the maximum velocity as well as the velocity
that the block started with when it was coming in V₀.
We can say that for part two, the time it takes is simply equal to the period of the T/2.
Alright, now let's put these three times together.
If we add together these three times and substitute in the period for the oscillations
of a spring, we get this equation for the time it takes the block to move away from the timer
and return back to it, and we know that we want this time to be equal exactly to 1 s.
And solving this equation for V₀, I get that the original speed to be equal to 1.08 m/s. Great job!